qu'est-ce qui est noirs et jaunes et
poilues et qui retombe toujours sur ses
pattes et batteries batteries vides
il ya des décisions importantes à
prendre pour ce soir les mecs
alors vous voyez qu est ce qu était bien
de même au cube du poisson ou autre bel
adieu alenia les femmes y avoir
téléphoné pour coiffer une amère au nord
j'ai monté mon site s'appelle à doc
mailloux 400 blague tu t'es encore remis
à faire le maquereau nous
karima ben watt 0 hormis moi ça fait
longtemps
[Musique]
non seulement tu te fume jamais d'y
faire bouffer mais tu partages même pas
la mimine bravo c'est l'une des idées
gagnent là sous la voix de suite quand
ça m'attire et akram bien trop occupé à
triturer la boîte à craindre à quoi ces
lignes on doit tuer spectaculaire ils
doivent faire mâchoire lie le sexe
bienvenue à vous fait rien a dit colegos
veut dire que j'ai pas attendre
[Musique]